hey there everybody I am Walter Binet
dziak and this is top five with this
directors pence feature-film Dunkirk
still in theatres I thought it was
finally time for this list today we're
taking a look at one of my all-time
favorite directors so hold on to your
seats because things are about to get
Nolan II Christopher Nolan is one of the
best directors working today from the
release of memento and mm leading into
his Dark Knight trilogy and beyond
Nolan is one of the most prolific voices
in film this century for better or worse
he started trends that are still being
followed to a certain degree as he
redefined superhero films as we knew
that but Nolan is so much more than just
a great Batman director his films take
us on complex journeys that reward the
audience upon multiple viewings his
signature presentation and strong handle
on story almost never disappoint like
many others I discovered his work
starting with Batman Begins and has been
hooked ever since
his movies connect with me and millions
of other people in ways that dazzle
astonish and stick with you long after
you see them these are the top 5 best
Christopher Nolan movies number 5
momento momento is a film school
favorite and started Nolan's mainstream
career in a very unique way Leonard
Shelby suffered a major head injury
while trying to fight his wife's
murderers he now has a rare form of
memory loss where he is unable to create
new memories even so his life consists
of hunting down the one surviving man
who killed his wife with the help of his
questionable friend teddy
Leonard uses Conditioning pictures and
tattoos to remind himself of his mission
supposedly this is being remade pretty
soon
can't wait for the momento cinematic
universe everyone who's seen this movie
knows how great and different it is the
story structure is more than just a
gimmick like a lot of Nolan's later
films amento lends itself to multiple
watching I still discover new details
every time I see it since the narrative
is nonlinear it forces the viewer to pay
attention to as many aspects as they can
process while the movie plays on you
start to piece things together lots of
particulars are left open to
interpretation which makes part of the
mystery of memento
much more intriguing I've been all sorts
of other considerations legal
responsibility large financial losses
the performances are pretty solid here -
I think joy Pantoliano is the standout
as Leonard's friend Teddy his presence
makes every scene he's in more layered
the car that's nice you should lock hey
fucker you Teddy your buddy
Rubick Sammy remember Sammy you told me
about Sammy G what the fuck are you
doing in my car what you sent two young
with one with the memory guy Pierce does
a really good job playing someone who
can't remember what's happening from
scene to scene but can feel when
something's off there are subtleties he
plays with that greatly benefitted
performance looks lasting that you do
remember my wife that's sweet
dying I remember my wife time
carrie-anne moss is also a nice addition
to the film her characters motivations
inject an unpredictability to Leonard's
predicament
thus when they interact it's always
different so next time you see me will
you remember me
my Mickey will
this is a must-see for film lovers its
story construction editing pacing tone
and characters Nick memento a modern
classic what was I doing
number four Batman Begins in 2005 I was
a 16 year old kid and saw this movie
with no real expectations when I left
the theater something changed in me it
awakened an ambition that made me
desperately want to tell my own stories
with a determination that wasn't quite
there before as silly as it may sound I
owe a lot to this movie for really
kick-starting my love of both making and
analyzing films Bruce Wayne traveled the
world searching for the means to fight
injustice eventually Henri Ducard and
the League of Shadows find him and teach
him their ways Bruce relents when he
sees that the league's extreme teachings
don't match up with his own moral code
when the still determined orphan
millionaire returns to Gotham things
start falling into place for the birth
of the Batman because of memento people
were aware of Nolan before this but it
was Batman Begins that really
jump-started his career I love almost
everything about this movie it's not
flawless but it hit so many marks for me
as a Batman fan that I became obsessed
with the little details in and the extra
features of the DVD I spent hours
rewatching how they made certain
sequences and everything that went into
the creative process I was fascinated
with this film for a long time the look
and feel of Gotham is different here
than in the next two installments and I
might like this version a little more I
love the idea of the Narrows and how
much time we spent there that none
Begins was a wide-scale film but Gotham
felt very intimate to me we were in the
dirty corners the crevices that no one
saw that meant fit very well into this
world and I was a touch disappointed
they didn't really expand on some of
these areas in the Dark Knight or rise
it that scene at the dock is still one
of the best live-action Batman sequences
ever
we're IO here the performances here are
mostly top-notch
I love bail as Batman and Bruce I think
this is his best performance of the
trilogy Bale is driving the action and
has a lot of emotions to play around
with to show off how great of an actor
he is also early on here the Batman
voice is more subdued it's deeper and
less raspy as opposed to where it went
in the next two movies
Falcone symptom to kill you why he
rattled his cage
what's this leverage for what to get
things moving liam neeson also brings
his signature styles of this film his
motivations are pretty clear and they
build a relationship up with Bruce in a
believable way I enjoyed their chemistry
I wasn't always here in the mountains
once I had a wife
my great love
she was taken from me gary oldman is Jim
Gordon shined more in the following
installment but here he's a damn good
future Commissioner he also just really
looks the part quick shoutout to Killian
Murphy for being a creepy scarecrow in
and out of the mask that character
deserves more but with the time he had I
liked him a lot
Murphy is just a really good actor and I
don't think he gets enough credit also
Morgan Freeman is great as Lucius Fox
but what else is there didn't you get
the memo
we have to talk about my favorite Alfred
Michael Caine was more active here than
we saw in previous iterations I think he
nailed this part as I've gotten older
I've grown more attached to Alfred as a
character and behind Bruce and maybe
dick racing he's my favorite member of
the bat standard we see the relationship
between him and Bruce stay consistent
and begins and change in future movie
but the emotion alfred brings to this
film is phenomenal and Michael Caine
will always be my favorite on-screen
version what do we force
so that we should learn to pick
ourselves up given up on me
Emma let's just fix one thing there we
go the last performance I want to
mention is Katie Holmes as Rachel Dawes
I don't care what anyone says I thought
she was leaps and bounds better for the
parts and Maggie Gyllenhaal in The Dark
Knight
Holmes isn't a heavy hitter like Baylor
Caine but I thought she was pretty good
in this movie I believe Rachel and
Bruce's chemistry and that they were
childhood friends
good people like your parents who'll
stand against injustice their God what
chance does Gotham have when the good
people do nothing Hans Zimmer and James
Newton Howard created a score that is so
emotional and heavy I love it it may not
be as iconic as any Elfman's Batman 89
soundtrack but for this universe it was
perfect I used to go back and watch the
credits of this movie just to listen to
the music at the end it connected with
me immensely
[Applause]
[Music]
I think I was the right age in the right
frame of mind and this was just the
right movie at the right time for me
it's also one of the last films I saw at
my hometown theater before it closed
down so it holds a special significance
I love it for introducing me to Nolan's
work and opening my mind to the
possibility of actually really trying to
be a filmmaker myself number three the
prestige everyone talks about insomnia
being no one's forgotten great work and
it is but I don't see many people
talking about how amazing the prestige
is either they spend Christopher priests
1995 novel the prestige portrays a
bitter rivalry of two magicians at the
end of the 19th century Robert Angier
blamed Alfred Borden for a magic trick
gone tragically wrong and the pair begin
to one-up each other as their individual
careers progress and grow however this
isn't just a professional grudge things
are personal and lives are put in danger
and here's obsession with a trick of
Borden's leads him to pursue severe
measures in his quest to be the superior
magician and man if you haven't seen the
prestige the less I say about it the
better
I think the only real way for you to
understand just how good this movie is
is to watch it two to three times I can
honestly say I enjoyed it the most upon
the last rewatch I'll quickly mention
that Christian Bale and Hugh Jackman get
career performances in this film they
are both amazing and you won't get how
amazing they actually are until you
watch the movie multiple times a real
magician tries to in vain something new
that other magicians are going to
scratch their heads over you're not I
suppose you have such a twin mr. Borden
that you do you can't just shut it to me
no no no's could do more trick any trick
can be duplicated right mr. cutter on
also Michael Caine is awesome as usual
and David Bowie is as cool as ever
so this is the great dental I took a lot
of notes on this one and have a lot to
say but I think a ton of people look
past this movie and going filmography
and that shouldn't be happening just go
watch the prestige if you've only seen
it once watch it again pay attention to
the detail it's a thoroughly rewarding
experience when you pick up on the
subtle hints drop in everything that's
happening number two the dark night for
years now people have talked at nauseam
about how amazing the dark night is it's
not just a great comic book movie since
Batman has been on the streets of Gotham
crime have gone down sharply as police
lieutenant Jim Gordon and District
Attorney Harvey Dent continue to round
up the bigger crime bosses a new class
of criminal starts to gain traction the
Joker is something Batman is never dealt
with before this agent of chaos turns to
city's plans for salvation on their head
and aims to show everyone the only
sensible way to live in this world is
without rules all the way through the
dark night just feels like a big deal
and it is it changed how comic book
movies were perceived people really
started taking them seriously as great
movies on their own beginning with this
thus far I think plenty of fans still
consider this the pinnacle of what a
near-perfect comic book film is Marvel
Studios has had their own success of
course in a completely different way but
the Dark Knight is the singular film we
can point to that is probably the most
widely accepted as something that
transcended its own meeting Heath Ledger
created an icon and advanced the legend
with his version of the Joker no matter
how much it's been said it doesn't make
it any less true Ledger Joker is one of
the most memorable character portrayals
in film history his death has seemed to
only deepen people's fascination with
the role how about a magic trick
I'm gonna make this pencil disappear
it's the first time I saw this movie
people applauded loudly after that scene
Ledger had us all on the edge of our
seats the entire time he was on screen
see their morals their code it's a bad
joke
dropped at the first sign of trouble the
only as good as the world that allows
them to be because of how brilliant
Ledger was a few other great
performances were overshadowed
I think Aaron Eckhart as Harvey Dent is
really underappreciated he was
extraordinary here one of the games
and that feel I wanted everyone else is
on their a-game bale cane Oldman Freeman
Gyllenhaal sees your life
you can't leave something like that to
chance well almost everyone
I mean how many great lines can you
recite from this movie odds are a lot
you either die a hero you something
Ellen Ellen why so serious some men just
want to watch the world burn because if
the hero Gotham deserves but not the one
it needs right now the themes are
obvious but woven perfectly into the
story and characters this film will
continue to resonate with people for
years to come and it will be remembered
as something truly special Christopher
Nolan has a list of great films to his
name and it was very difficult to leave
some of them out so before we get to
number one here they are as honorable
mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Christopher
Nolan movie is inception in my opinion
this is still no one's masterpiece Dom
Cobb specializes in stealing important
secrets from people's minds through
sharing dreams he has been on the run
since he was framed for his wife's death
and has been making ends meet by working
for clients that wish to obtain a secret
from arrival when a man named Saito
offers him a way back home the catch
ends up being Inception planting an idea
in someone's head instead of stealing it
this is a risky process with a very low
level of success Cobb decides to go
through with it and puts together a team
who are each the best at what they do as
they go deeper into their subject psyche
the situation becomes more and more
hazardous whether you think the sharing
dreams idea had been done before or not
it was never done on this scale
inception is brilliant genius whatever
positive adjectives you can think of I
was in all of this movie the first few
times I saw it and now every time I
watch it
I am truly appreciative of the effort
put forth in making this movie a reality
the rotating hallway scene is a perfect
example
that was a real rotating set this movie
becomes more impressive the more you
hear about what they did behind the
scenes and it's an astounding
achievement no doubt the performances
all work really well here without these
actors playing interesting characters
that inhabit the story the dream gimmick
would be just that DiCaprio plays a
sympathetic yet mysterious lead in
domkop we're rooting for him while not
fully trusting him for reasons explained
in the film Leo handled that balance
well some dad don't tell me to calm down
this was your job god damn it these are
your responsibilities you are meant to
check Fisher's background thoroughly we
are not prepared for this type of
violent we have dealt with social
security before will be a little more
careful we're going to be fine so it's
not a part of place dying for God isn't
about Tom Hardy and Joseph gordon-levitt
have a fun back and forth throughout
you mustn't be afraid to dream a little
bigger darling Ellen page's Ariadne is
sort of the audience point of view as
she discovers how this dream business
all works I like to roll Tilly and
Murphy killed it as Robert Fisher I'm
glad he had more to do here and he had a
great scene in the third act of the film
Marion Cotillard as Cobbs wife Maul is
truly haunted I think some of her scenes
are the closest to a Nolan horror film
we've gotten yet ultimately the movies
dream gimmick is held together by Cobb
the emotional story throughout the film
with his arc at the center it reaches a
level that lifts inception to Nolan's
best movie and greatest achievement at
this point in his career you're reading
some train a train that will take you
far away you know where your house is
turn will take you but you don't know
for sure that it can that Dunkirk was
amazing in theaters and I suggest you
check it out there if at all possible
it continues Nolan's streak of great
films that are very different from his
others yet have a familiar touch I
always look forward to what he comes up
with next it's guaranteed to be
something special I want to hear what
you guys think what is your favorite
Christopher Nolan movie leave me a
comment and let me know or or more
content subscribe to my personal channel
youtube.com/ / awesome Walter like my
new Facebook page facebook.com slash
awesome Walter B and follow along on
Twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future come
back next week as he hi pepper fan group
what are you doing here I'm just trying
to wake you up wake me up
heck hmm bill hmm am I still asleep
what's going on why so serious
he pleasure choker oh my god I was
having a terrible nightmare well let's
put a smile back on that face this is
real I thought I was gonna kill me I'm
not gonna kill you I'm just gonna hurt
you
really really bad
[Music]
you